David: And just confirming. Now that I've started recording, are you comfortable with recording today?
Anna Mills: Do? What were you at? What.
David: Oh, are you comfortable with me recording this screen.
Anna Mills: Oh, yeah, that's fine.
David: Great, great, great great
David: Would you want your video on, or should I turn mine off? What are you most comfortable with.
Anna Mills: I wasn't able to get it to work.
David: Oh, don't!
Anna Mills: Know why, but Zoom has not been friendly the last couple of days with
Anna Mills: I I don't know. I don't know what's going on with it.
David: No worries. Okay.
Anna Mills: I don't know if there was an update, and the government decided they didn't like something, so I don't. I don't know.
David: That's yeah, yeah, no. I know that Zoom can have some issues for
David: va folks, so I'll go ahead and turn mine off, too, so we can all kinda
David: be on the same place there. But
David: okay, let's go ahead. And could you tell me a little bit about your role at the Va.
David: It's the start.
Anna Mills: So I am a. I am a public affairs specialist.
Anna Mills: I also am outreach coordinator and the pact coordinator for the State that I'm in.
Anna Mills: I've been in public affairs for about 6 years.
Anna Mills: And the entire time I've been in public affairs. I've
Anna Mills: worked on our like our in like our Internet like this, and then intranet
Anna Mills: you know all of our social media stuff like that. So.
David: Got it?
David: And then how often are you using the Cms to upload images.
Anna Mills: several times a week. I've several times today I've been on it.
David: Several times a day. And what kind of content types are you typically creating.
Anna Mills: So a lot of the
Anna Mills: a lot of the repeated ones are are events, you know.
David: Yeah.
Anna Mills: And then
Anna Mills: we've had some, you know, newer programs that have come to our facility, you know, or
Anna Mills: we have like resident programs, you know, for, like our pharmacy, like internships, stuff like that.
Anna Mills: those get rate, those get updated and we put like the pictures. You know what I mean of the
Anna Mills: you know, of the interns and stuff like that on there.
David: Okay, so mainly like detail pages and event pages.
David: Yeah, right?
Anna Mills: Yeah.
David: Fantastic. And I'm very curious about those event pages. For the images. Are you selecting the images yourself.
David: or do you receive them?
Anna Mills: Well, the only that's like that's 1 of the things is when you go to like to create an event. The only image that you can put on. There is the event. You know. Have a like an event banner kind of thing up at top.
David: Yeah.
Anna Mills: That's the only
Anna Mills: image you could put on. There.
Anna Mills: So.
Anna Mills: Yes.
Anna Mills: I do. I'm I'm the one that picks those things out.
Anna Mills: I'm also the one that makes them.
David: You may, what and when you say, make them you, what are you referring to?
Anna Mills: In adobe.
David: You make them. Okay, you're you're you're making them in adobe
Anna Mills: Kind of have like a template for
Anna Mills: for these, you know, for the events, and then just changing like titles. And you know, stuff like that.
Anna Mills: This is all it is is
Anna Mills: all the banner is is you know what the event is like we're having next week. We're having, you know, it's pow mia recognition day.
Anna Mills: So we're having events.
Anna Mills: So that one just that's all it says is, you know.
Anna Mills: national pow mia recognition day with like our logo, and seal and stuff.
David: Got it. There's.
Anna Mills: Not.
Anna Mills: That's pretty much all you can do in that. It's a 7 7 by 2 ratio.
Anna Mills: so there's not much room to do much else with it.
David: Ideally. What would you like to be doing with it?
Anna Mills: So for the the events. It would be nice if
Anna Mills: if
Anna Mills: I think the header is fine like having that header on there, you know it's fine, because, you know, when they go on the page. And it's you know it's big. Everyone sees it, you know that part's great.
Anna Mills: but having an option, for just like when you're building like a page. And you have the different options for like a photo, or, you know.
Anna Mills: like links, or whatever. It would be nice to to be able to have those things
Anna Mills: have those things in there sometimes are, especially for more information.
Anna Mills: sometimes for like for our, we have a homeless veteran program happening next Thursday.
Anna Mills: and
Anna Mills: we recently they were on the news with it. Well, I want to put that in. You know what I mean. Like, I want to put that picture in there
Anna Mills: of that like, add to it.
Anna Mills: and, you know, put that link to the story in there. So people can get more information and understand further, like what it is and who they should share it with, and all those types of things, but the events are really
Anna Mills: they're not
Anna Mills: There's not a lot to it. When you know when you go on that page.
Anna Mills: it would be nice.
David: Yeah. So for that one photo that you are uploading.
David: Are you? You said you're just reusing. You have a template in like adobe
David: illustrator, Photoshop.
Anna Mills: I mean I I did it. I did part. I mean I did it. It's like illustrator, but I also sometimes go to adobe express. If I'm in a hurry.
David: Yeah.
Anna Mills: No, not very fancy.
Anna Mills: no.
David: yeah. And you're you're making the banner yourself.
David: The size requirements are those things that are already like inputted in your adobe files? Or are you
David: cropping it
David: within the
David: drupal cms.
Anna Mills: So. No, no, I'm not cropping it
Anna Mills: at all.
Anna Mills: The when you put it in drupal. It says it will automatically crop to a 7
Anna Mills: 7, you know, 7, 2 ratio. So when I make it, I've I've that's why I have that template to work off of, and it's a 7, you know, 7 to 2 ratio set up already. That's why I just
Anna Mills: sometimes I'll duplicate it, and you know, so I have the original file. But duplicate it, and then
Anna Mills: just change, you know. Change the duplicated file
Anna Mills: to whatever it is needed.
David: Okay. And do you ever find yourself using the media library to
David: for for anything.
Anna Mills: Ever, and I always I know it asks every time you put a photo in there, you know. Can something be reused?
Anna Mills: And I say no
Anna Mills: one. All of all the files like this that like say these, you know the banners for the events
Anna Mills: they are. I mean it has our our logo on it. So it's not just like the Va logo. It's
Anna Mills: Lexiton, va healthcare system. So if someone else used it.
David: It wouldn't make any sense.
Anna Mills: No, not at all. And then, you know, there's very few places where
Anna Mills: I can share those photos now.
Anna Mills: the like the Va. Has, you know, a certain amount of
Anna Mills: You know, there's there's rules about the the photos that we take of people, you know, staff included
Anna Mills: and how they can be used.
Anna Mills: So if someone signs a consent form
Anna Mills: for us to use
Anna Mills: for a specific story or a, you know, specific page on our Internet.
Anna Mills: I can't give other people permission to use it because they didn't.
Anna Mills: Does, you know, does does that make sense.
David: Yeah, no, that makes complete sense, because it's not for that specific purpose. It's it's.
Anna Mills: Yeah.
David: 4 year, 4 year story, 4 year detail page, whatever. But it's not.
Anna Mills: Yeah, so it's.
David: And exist.
Anna Mills: Might be an excellent photo, but if if someone wanted to use it for something that's not for that, you know not that purpose, not, you know, whatever. Then?
Anna Mills: you know we would be breaking what we had consent for so.
David: Got it.
Anna Mills: Yeah. So sometimes I I just I. So I don't put my photos in there. And it's just
Anna Mills: when you go in there. And you look at the photos?
Anna Mills: I mean, I haven't really found anything that I thought you know I'd want to use. I guess.
David: Got it, got it.
David: So going moving, moving along here to our 1st task.
David: I was hoping you could open your Cms log in, and we could kind of walk through
David: an event
David: creation.
David: on your screen share.
Anna Mills: You said an event.
David: An event. Yeah, okay, so we'll go. We'll we'll make. I kind of want to watch your workflow while creating an event.
David: and we can talk about it. As we complete the task.
Anna Mills: Okay.
Anna Mills: share. My screen
Anna Mills: test.
David: Good. Okay, yeah. We're already in an event.
Anna Mills: Yeah, to be fair was our. I was in I was already in here when you guys when we started this.
David: Perfect. So what I
David: we don't have to do all the top
David: name and date and time. If we just scroll down just a bit.
David: Just kind of walk me through how you upload an image
David: where the image is coming from that process.
Anna Mills: Okay, so you know.
Anna Mills: add Media, I
Anna Mills: here, you know how Lexington does it. We have. We use the leaf
Anna Mills: and
Anna Mills: It's just a system where people ask us to advertise or print, or whatever all the different public affairs things. So they'll have an event.
Anna Mills: you know that they have coming up.
Anna Mills: and
Anna Mills: one of them was
Anna Mills: the most recent request that I got was this, pow.
Anna Mills: you know, MIA event?
David: And you're you. You receive it
David: like a word document like you just showed me. That's how you're receiving it from leave.
Anna Mills: Sometimes. Yes, they don't. They don't design the things, and even if they did.
Anna Mills: they don't.
Anna Mills: you know, like
Anna Mills: the
Anna Mills: graphics and stuff. I don't know where they get some of these things, so I
Anna Mills: I don't use them because
Anna Mills: I don't know for a while if that makes sense but so what I'll do if you know, I was actually in adobe earlier.
Anna Mills: And
Anna Mills: I went through and created, you know, the Facebook post.
Anna Mills: you know Facebook, Instagram post size.
Anna Mills: the Facebook event size.
Anna Mills: which is different than our size. So I'm creating, like all these different size graphics of the same exact thing.
Anna Mills: And then
Anna Mills: I you know I have.
Anna Mills: I have a folder for like marketing type stuff, and
Anna Mills: I just I just drop it in here.
Anna Mills: that's all I do.
Anna Mills: So
Anna Mills: And I name it. You know this one that I'm going to put it on. There is, you know it? Says Pow MIA day drupal event, you know. So I know it's for
Anna Mills: like this.
David: Okay.
Anna Mills: And yeah.
Anna Mills: and usually I just I mean, I just write out what it is. You know, pow.
Anna Mills: MIA, you know event banner.
Anna Mills: and then I find me
Anna Mills: and then it's once again. It's just the pow you know, mia
Anna Mills: mission
Anna Mills: events.
Anna Mills: huge banner.
Anna Mills: And then, even though I know it automatically corrects to 7, too. I always you know what I mean. Just so I can see it to make sure it looks good.
Anna Mills: I like that part.
Anna Mills: and then I unclick it.
Anna Mills: and then I always just save and insert.
David: What's the difference between select and insert?
Anna Mills: So when I've done save and select sometimes it doesn't show up.
David: Hmm.
Anna Mills: It's like I have to go back and find it.
Anna Mills: but when I do save it and inserts it's there, so
Anna Mills: I don't know. But that was my, that's been my experience.
David: Your experience. Okay? And before we click, save and insert just a couple of other questions as so, going
David: above a little bit, what might happen if
David: you did? 3 by 2,
David: as your crop size.
Anna Mills: It doesn't. It doesn't change the size of my image. It just shows what would
Anna Mills: you know what I mean? I can choose what part to show it.
David: And and if you were to
David: have like click this and save an insert.
David: what do you think would happen.
Anna Mills: This it. This is, that's all that would show up right there.
Anna Mills: I think.
Anna Mills: but it does say that.
Anna Mills: you know it automatically crops to 7 2. So I don't know. It could just make this, you know, 7 2 like make that part big, but I'm not sure.
David: Got it.
David: and then scrolling up a little bit more.
David: What's the difference?
David: Between the description and the alternative text?
Anna Mills: So the alternative text is the 508 compliance part. So screen readers are going to.
Anna Mills: This is what the screen readers will pick up for people who have visual
Anna Mills: You know, disabilities. The description
Anna Mills: I have no idea. I mean I don't. You don't see it. I don't see it on the page.
Anna Mills: But this is not. This is not what shows up for the screen readers. So
Anna Mills: I make sure that the alternative text, and in this part the description is not required.
Anna Mills: But this one, I make sure, is very clear about what it is.
David: Since it's not required. I'm curious why you fill it out.
David: Why do you build this up?
Anna Mills: I don't.
Anna Mills: I don't know, because it's a blank box, and I like to put stuff there, and I mean have it. I guess.
David: Got it. Got it?
David: Okay?
David: Well,
David: yeah, go ahead, and we can close this out.
David: I have another task for us now where I'm going to go ahead and share with you a link.
David: It's gonna be a prototype link.
David: So that means everything will work, you know, exactly as expected, but for the most part it should
David: mimic what you're used to. So I'm going ahead and sending it in the Zoom chat.
Anna Mills: Okay.
David: Working
David: and then let's go to the in the left nav sidebar. There's proposed Flow. Let's click on that one.
Anna Mills: Okay.
David: Okay?
David: So
David: now, I'm showing you a potential redesign of the image upload system.
David: Imagine you have started to create a new event for veterans.
David: You've entered in your date and time.
David: and now it's time to upload. An image.
David: Please show me how you would do that.
David: And yeah, unfortunately, you're not able to drag and drop in this. But
David: you were you. You were moving your mouse to do that. Is that all right?
Anna Mills: Yeah.
David: Okay, perfect.
Anna Mills: I'm using what's available there because
David: Yeah, that's perfect. That's perfect.
Anna Mills: But yeah, I would. I would normally probably drag and and drop it.
Anna Mills: It's just easier. It's just easier.
David: Yeah, perfect. Yeah.
Anna Mills: When you have, you know, when you have all the you know so much going on.
David: And ideally, this would be able to like, move up and down like as as expected.
Anna Mills: All right.
David: Yeah. Well, tell me what you're thinking as you click that.
Anna Mills: Yeah, I mean, it's good.
Anna Mills: If
Anna Mills: the alternative text, yeah, I mean, that's good. And then
David: Yeah. And again, this prototype
David: is, yeah, like simulating you, typing it in.
Anna Mills: Yeah.
Anna Mills: okay.
David: But tell me about that experience.
Anna Mills: I like it a lot better. It it I do. It looks a lot cleaner and
Anna Mills: I guess.
Anna Mills: Well, I guess one thing. I I don't think I
Anna Mills: I saw.
Anna Mills: or I remember. Did it ask if you wanted to save it in the.
Anna Mills: you know, like it normally does like save the, you know, for everyone else to use. Does it add.
David: It did. It did not ask that.
Anna Mills: Okay, so we're not going to do that. Any like is that going to be taken away? Or does it automatically save for other people's use?
David: What do you think should happen.
Anna Mills: no, I don't think that we should. I don't think
Anna Mills: I don't think it makes sense.
Anna Mills: for I mean some programs, sure national programs, you know, if it's like adobe stock footage, or something like that. But once again, if I have a picture of an even an employee.
Anna Mills: but especially like a veteran or their family members. And I've said, I'm going to use these photos for this story or this thing on our, you know, intranet social media blah blah. But then they find themselves, you know, on like California's Internet page.
Anna Mills: But that wasn't on their consent.
Anna Mills: I don't.
Anna Mills: I wouldn't like it if it was me.
David: Sure. And but and I'm curious. What about reusage
David: for you
David: like, for example, if there's a monthly
David: coffee chat
David: and you have a banner that always is for every event. Monthly coffee, chat.
Anna Mills: Well, I mean, I have like for our files that we that you know that we have here.
Anna Mills: you know, have them.
Anna Mills: I guess, broken down and saved. And you know what I mean in a way where it's easier for me. It's easy for me to to just grab it. I know where it's at.
Anna Mills: Everybody in our department knows where it's at.
Anna Mills: There's no mistaking it.
David: So you're not looking to the media library for that. You have your own internal system for
David: categorizing your images, keeping them, having them ready.
Anna Mills: Yeah, I don't ever have it on the the media library.
David: Okay?
David: so what stands out to you about this new design?
Anna Mills: It's it's less of the the.
Anna Mills: The way it was before was a little bit more clunky. I guess I can just upload an image. I don't have to worry, you know. Can go either. Go.
Anna Mills: I like it separated the upload image, and then you know the search
Anna Mills: and the media content.
Anna Mills: And then when you get into the upload image, that description is taken off there. Because why do we need it?
Anna Mills: I like that a lot. It looks a lot better.
Anna Mills: you know. We'll save some time.
David: Time
David: and tell me about that.
David: the page, the cropping page.
David: you
David: and we can go back if if
Anna Mills: Now. So for this one, because it's it's, you know, this 7 to 2 ratio. It automatically went to that.
Anna Mills: That that's
Anna Mills: I like that better
Anna Mills: if it's only going to be a 7 to 2 ratio and nothing else.
Anna Mills: Why do we have, you know, for the old one? Why do we need all those listed?
Anna Mills: So?
Anna Mills: yeah, no. I like that.
Anna Mills: Only have the thing that's available.
Anna Mills: Then nobody accidentally clicks the wrong thing, because that probably happens. And then also,
Anna Mills: you just get to preview it. You don't have to select it, you know, to preview it.
David: Yeah.
Anna Mills: Yeah.
David: And
David: are there any features
David: in this that you found may be confusing or unnecessary?
Anna Mills: For for this!
David: Yes.
David: but there's.
David: Proposed, flow.
Anna Mills: I don't think so. No.
David: Are there any improvements you'd like to see prototype.
Anna Mills: No, I mean, this is great
Anna Mills: taking away things that we that we don't need and simplifying it. It's just, you know, that
Anna Mills: that is great.
David: That's great.
David: Okay?
David: now.
David: you like. So my goal really is to make sure that you have the easiest possible experience uploading an image
David: if you had a magic wand.
David: and you can make the perfect image uploader that works for you. That makes your life easier. That saves you time.
David: What might.
David: what features might that include?
Anna Mills: hmm!
Anna Mills: Don't I mean I
Anna Mills: I
Anna Mills: I like it just the way it is. I like, as long as you know, doing the upload part, you know. Fine, but
Anna Mills: The like drag, you know. I prefer like the drag and drop.
Anna Mills: I like that better.
Anna Mills: So as long as that stays around.
Anna Mills: it's it's easier.
David: It's easier.
Anna Mills: For me anyways.
David: Got it. Got it? Okay?
David: Yes, I promise you we will not take away the drag and drop.
David: Yes, don't don't worry about the drag and drop, cause that is, yeah. Such a good feature. I.
Anna Mills: Do you like the
Anna Mills: You know how? When you put that in, there it goes, and it shows you exactly like what this you know, the 7
Anna Mills: 7 2 ratio like it only shows that because that's the only one that's available.
Anna Mills: It's a little confusing, because the event page is not the only page that has
Anna Mills: only one will will only show one size of photo
Anna Mills: But
Anna Mills: you know in my head.
Anna Mills: I'm not. I'm not trying to be rude, but in my head, why are they there? If I can't use them, just have the ones I can use.
David: Other ones I can use.
Anna Mills: Yeah, if it's not a feature for this specific
Anna Mills: you know creation, the, you know, the create create event. Then if it's not a feature that can be used on these types of pages, then, you know, but
Anna Mills: don't have them on. There.
David: Got it.
David: Now I'm curious, because it sounds like you're working on pages. Besides, events.
David: like detail pages and things like that.
David: Maybe you could walk me through
David: one of your other pages that involves uploading
David: images.
Anna Mills: Okay.
Anna Mills: should I close this out.
David: Yeah, you can close this one out.
Anna Mills: Okay.
Anna Mills: so
Anna Mills: do do. I'm trying to think of the last one I created.
Anna Mills: We'll just go to
Anna Mills: my home page and see.
Anna Mills: See, I have was in here today.
David: Got it? Got it?
David: Okay? It's not.
Anna Mills: So our optometry Residency program
Anna Mills: uploaded this. It's a photo of our campus.
David: Got it.
Anna Mills: Oh, and
Anna Mills: this photo
Anna Mills: stuff there's that's stuff like that.
David: Sure. And when you're building these pages.
David: are you? How are you
David: kind of uploading these images and keeping track of the site like it actually, could you press preview for me for a second big preview button.
Anna Mills: And what I do when I'm creating a page like this.
Anna Mills: and I'm uploading these images. I am
Anna Mills: I do this. I look at the preview a lot
Anna Mills: to make sure that it's not. You know that it's sizing.
Anna Mills: you know, looking the way that I want it, no matter how you choose the crop, or whatever I want to make sure it looks right, you know.
David: Right.
Anna Mills: So.
David: And are you editing? The width of these images.
David: like in your Photoshop.
David: are in your illustrator.
Anna Mills: Yeah, I I do. If I do, if I need to. I
Anna Mills: I did not take this photo. The program actually did. But usually we are taking photos, and, you know, trying to take
Anna Mills: intentional photos. So
Anna Mills: you know, you don't have to. We're not having to to crop them. If I'm taking a photo specifically for the Internet, you know what I mean. Like, I'm trying to make sure that I'm taking exactly what we need.
David: But I'm curious.
David: You see how this image is kind of like the full width of the
David: of the section.
David: How might you make the image of the campus that full would if you wanted to do that.
Anna Mills: How would I?
David: Yes.
Anna Mills: Dude.
Anna Mills: I guess I would.
Anna Mills: if I can do this.
Anna Mills: I don't know if I can do this here
Anna Mills: Nope don't want to do that.
Anna Mills: I don't know.
Anna Mills: Let me see.
Anna Mills: Okay.
Anna Mills: yeah. I mean, it says to fill up to, to fill up the full available width of you know the content area.
Anna Mills: But you know, from adding
Anna Mills: media.
Anna Mills: let's see
Anna Mills: do, do.
Anna Mills: Don't mind my folders.
Anna Mills: building thoughtful Southeasley
Anna Mills: so
Anna Mills: open.
Anna Mills: I mean, I think it is just what it is. I don't think that there's a way. I guess I could crop.
Anna Mills: you know, to make it.
Anna Mills: but that's just cropping it. That's not really sizing it.
Anna Mills: right? So we have to
Anna Mills: do that beforehand
Anna Mills: before we put it in here.
Anna Mills: And
Anna Mills: probably it would. That would probably be nice to, you know, to to change.
Anna Mills: that's
Anna Mills: a lot of.
Anna Mills: I guess. Work on the front end, you know, to be able to put things in here.
Anna Mills: but yeah.
Anna Mills: I know that even on some of our
Anna Mills: on some of the other systems that I work on.
Anna Mills: yeah, it has to be, you know, it has to be a certain size, just like, you know, the 7 by 2 for the events, you know, just like that. But you can choose if it's going to be so many like so many pixels across, like, how big it is, how big it shows on the screen.
Anna Mills: But yeah, we don't have. I don't. I guess we don't have that option here.
David: Got it.
Anna Mills: So.
David: So what might make this experience easier is kind. You're you're saying.
David: the ability to manipulate the size.
Anna Mills: Yes, so
Anna Mills: that that would be helpful.
David: Got it.
David: Okay? And do you know, is there anywhere that you can tell how big the image you're uploading
David: is at this moment.
David: So I know we talked about that 1,000 pixels.
Anna Mills: Yeah,
Anna Mills: is. Yeah. So if I looked at this picture that I'm you know, doing specifically.
Anna Mills: I can go into the the properties of it, but it doesn't show me like here on the screen, or anything doesn't show me what it is.
Anna Mills: Would that be?
David: I mean, that would be helpful for you.
Anna Mills: Yes, to know what it is. Yes.
Anna Mills: especially if like on the page that you know I'm showing.
Anna Mills: If you know I have this picture, and it's of the facility.
Anna Mills: You know, and it's as small as it is. But the picture further down the page of the people is
Anna Mills: you know, a little bit bigger.
Anna Mills: actually a lot bigger. But
Anna Mills: But
Anna Mills: you know I what did it say to fill up the full page? It had to be a thousand
Anna Mills: pixels across.
David: Yeah, how do you feel about that language?
Anna Mills: It's I mean, it's not bad.
Anna Mills: but
Anna Mills: I mean, because I mean we deal we deal with. You know those sizes all the time
Anna Mills: when you open any adobe.
Anna Mills: you know, you know new document, even if it's in express it, it goes by Pixel. If you go by, you know if you want to change it to inches or something. You have to make, you know, to do that, but it shows up in pixels, so I don't think the pixel part is a problem.
Anna Mills: But it, you know. It says, to fill up the full available width of the content area on all screens.
David: Would there be any situations where
David: you wouldn't want to have a full sized image.
Anna Mills: yeah.
Anna Mills: I mean, maybe
Anna Mills: I
Anna Mills: I you know, I don't think that like the photo that's on like, I'm going to go back after this conversation, and and, you know, fix the photo that's here of those residents.
Anna Mills: because it doesn't need to be that big.
Anna Mills: And if that was the across the you know the screen, you know completely.
Anna Mills: Then that would you know what I mean like? That's it doesn't need to be that big.
Anna Mills: It's
Anna Mills: I think it detracts from the information that's on the screen.
David: The tracks from the information on the screen.
David: Got it so what would a good if there was like one standard size?
David: Should there be one standard size. Should you have the option.
Anna Mills: No, we should have options.
Anna Mills: cause you know.
Anna Mills: there's I have another page that I did, that I have all of like a pictures, and it's like all of our different facilities. You know it has. You know, we have. We have 2 main campuses, and then we have 4 community clinics, and it's
Anna Mills: I think it's at least
Anna Mills: you know, 8 or 8 or 900 pixels. You know what I mean. So it's it's a larger.
Anna Mills: It's a larger photo.
Anna Mills: But
Anna Mills: the
Anna Mills: when you look at when you look at a when I look at you know this photo that I was just uploading
Anna Mills: when I go into properties of it. It says the width is, you know, 5,100 pixels.
David: Hmm.
Anna Mills: So I don't know how it got from
Anna Mills: from from that to you know what we see
Anna Mills: here.
David: So this is 5,100 pixels, but it's not showing up
David: as far away.
Anna Mills: No, it's not.
Anna Mills: And that's in here.
David: Yeah.
David: we'll definitely make a note of this. It's it's interesting.
David: okay.
David: well, I really appreciate you taking the time to chat with us today? I just have a couple other questions. These are a little bit more
David: drupal overall.
David: so is there anything in the current drupal cms
David: and not just sticking with like images now.
David: but like anything else in your daily workflow that you feel is missing, or could be improved. To make your workflow a little easier.
Anna Mills: yes,
Anna Mills: I think that.
Anna Mills: So
Anna Mills: so when I when I when say, there's a program that doesn't have a page on our Internet. They want a new page, you know. Fine. We get all the information from them. Make sure everything's accurate, you know, if there's photos or whatever we get everything ready, and then we come in here.
Anna Mills: What I like to do when I am
Anna Mills: like building, you know, like a new page of, you know, for a program
Anna Mills: is to have
Anna Mills: the actual, not, I know this is a preview, but the actual
Anna Mills: Internet open. So you know. And I'm looking because I have to look and see like what it's going to be under. You know where it's going to go and
Anna Mills: when you create, when you create a page.
Anna Mills: You know you have to. You know the detail page.
Anna Mills: Like they're not. It doesn't show here. You know what I mean. Like. If I go to health services.
Anna Mills: that's not. I was looking for one. Specifically.
Anna Mills: it's not necessarily intuitive how to find
Anna Mills: some of the things that you need to change for a page if I go to the arseously campus.
Anna Mills: and we have here like preparing for your visit.
Anna Mills: here.
Anna Mills: and you know so it's the women veteran healthcare. I've had a lot of problems with this page.
Anna Mills: You know.
Anna Mills: So I go to it.
Anna Mills: But it's just what's on the front.
Anna Mills: you know, on the front of the there's another back page
Anna Mills: that you know, that has more information.
Anna Mills: But it's not.
Anna Mills: If there's going to be a detail page, you know, for a service.
Anna Mills: Then the other page that that the front page takes you to it, you know, and I shouldn't say want to say they should be linked.
Anna Mills: But when you are, when when I'm navigating, you know, and I'm using the side here, it's
Anna Mills: it's it's hard to find what you're looking for for things you've already done.
Anna Mills: if you have to update them.
Anna Mills: And I think I have spent
Anna Mills: way too much time, and maybe it's me, and
Anna Mills: I'm dumb because I couldn't figure it out.
Anna Mills: how to find some of these things.
Anna Mills: and I go to search. But
Anna Mills: it's
Anna Mills: it's diff. It's difficult. Sometimes when you're you know, you have to update.
Anna Mills: it's like 3 different pages, and one of them is hard to find.
Anna Mills: Does that make sense?
Anna Mills: Or did I just ramble on.
David: No, I I think I'm getting it just to reiterate. So we
David: an example might be the health Services page women's health.
David: veteran women under women's health.
David: It's hard to know where that page lived.
David: Is that what
David: you're getting at.
Anna Mills: So
Anna Mills: I'm going to open this.
Anna Mills: This is. This is the detail page.
Anna Mills: you know.
Anna Mills: but you don't make you don't just make a detail page. You have to make the Facility Health Service page.
Anna Mills: and it says where it's at. You know, the service location stuff like that, you know, appointments.
Anna Mills: Those 2 pages have to be made
Anna Mills: for
Anna Mills: you know, for a program.
Anna Mills: But on the front page.
Anna Mills: where where I showed you it listed that women's health.
Anna Mills: That's another page.
Anna Mills: and
Anna Mills: it doesn't.
Anna Mills: I've had to link that front page to these pages.
Anna Mills: It didn't have that set up right away.
Anna Mills: But to link them. These were not easy to find. You know, the
Anna Mills: the health service, the basic information for that program.
Anna Mills: These are not easy to find for me.
David: They're fine.
Anna Mills: No, and I go into the knowledge base.
Anna Mills: then look up stuff all the time.
David: Got it.
David: Got it? Well.
David: thank you so much, and I really appreciate you taking the time to chat with us today. And share your thoughts. Your feedback is so helpful to us as we continue to work on the site. Make sure really works for veterans and editors.
David: I wanted to ask if you had any questions for me, as we wrap up.
Anna Mills: No.
David: Hey? Well.
David: thank you so much again. Enjoy the rest of your day. Really appreciate this.
Anna Mills: Yeah, not a problem.
David: Thanks.